- [Instructor] Here are some equations
that are often used in pH calculations.
For example, let's say a solution
is formed at 25 degrees Celsius
and the solution has a pOH of 4.75,
and our goal is to
calculate the concentration
of hydronium ions in solution, H3O+.
One way to start this problem
is to use this equation,
pH plus pOH is equal to 14.00.
And we have the pOH equal to 4.75,
so we can plug that into our equation.
That gives us pH plus 4.75
is equal to 14.00.
And solving for the pH, we get
that the pH is equal to 9.25.
So we have the pH and our goal is to solve
for the concentration of hydronium ions,
and pH is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydronium ions.
So we can plug our pH
right into this equation.
So that would give us the pH which is 9.25
is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydronium ions.
Next, we need to solve
for the concentration
of hydronium ions.
So we could move the negative
sign over to the left side,
which gives us negative 9.25
is equal to the log of the
concentration of hydronium ions.
And to get rid of that log,
we can take 10 to both sides.
So that's gonna give us the
concentration of hydronium ions,
H3O+, is equal to 10 to the negative 9.25.
And 10 to the negative 9.25
is equal to 5.6 times
10 to the negative 10.
So the concentration of hydronium ions
in our solution at 25 degrees Celsius
is equal to 5.6 times 10
to the negative 10th molar.
Also notice that because
we had two decimal places
for our pH, we have the
concentration of hydronium ions
to two significant figures.
There's another way to
do the same problem.
Since we have the pOH,
we could use the pOH equation
to find the concentration
of hydroxide ions in solution.
So we would just need to plug
in the pOH into this equation
which gives us 4.75,
which is the pOH, is
equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydroxide ions.
Next, we can move the negative
sign over to the left side.
So negative 4.75 is equal to
the log of the concentration
of hydroxide ions.
And to get rid of the log, we
just take 10 to both sides.
10 to the negative 4.75
is equal to 1.8 times 10
to the negative fifth.
So the concentration of hydroxide ions
is equal to 1.8 times 10 to
the negative fifth molar.
So our goal is to find the concentration
of hydronium ions in solution,
and we have the concentration
of hydroxide ions in solution,
so we can use the Kw equation
because the concentration
of hydronium ions
times the concentration of
hydroxide ions is equal to Kw,
which is equal to 1.0 times
10 to the negative 14th
at 25 degrees Celsius.
So we can plug in the
concentration of hydroxide ions
into our equation.
That gives us 1.8 times
10 to the negative fifth
times the concentration of hydronium ions,
which we'll just write
as x in our equation
is equal to Kw
which is equal to 1.0 times
10 to the negative 14.
Solving for x,
we find the x is equal to 5.6
times 10 to the negative 10th.
So the concentration of hydronium ions
is equal to 5.6 times 10
to the negative 10th molar.
So even though we used
two different equations
from the first time we did this problem,
we ended up with the same answer
that we did the first time,
5.6 times 10 to the negative 10th molar.
So it doesn't really matter
which approach you take.
Finally, let's look at an example
where the temperature is
not 25 degrees Celsius.
Let's say, we have a sample of pure water
at 50 degrees Celsius,
and our goal is to calculate the pH.
Pure water is a neutral substance
which means the concentration
of hydronium ions, H3O+,
is equal to the concentration
of hydroxide ions, OH-.
Right now, we don't know what
those concentrations are,
but we know that the
concentration of hydronium ions
times the concentration of hydroxide ions
is equal to Kw.
However, we have to be careful because Kw
is only equal to 1.0
times 10 to negative 14th
at 25 degrees Celsius.
And at 50 degrees Celsius,
Kw is equal to 5.5 times
10 to the negative 14th.
So let's go ahead and write
Kw is equal to 5.5 times
10 to the negative 14th.
And if we make the concentration
of hydronium ions x,
then the concentration of hydroxide ions
would also have to be x
since the two are equal.
So we would have x times x
is equal to 5.5 times
10 to the negative 14th.
So that gives us x squared
is equal to 5.5 times
10 to the negative 14th.
And if we take the square
root of both sides,
we find that x is equal
to 2.3 times 10 to the negative seventh.
And since x is equal to the concentration
of hydronium ions in solution,
the concentration of hydronium ions
is 2.3 times 10 to the
negative seventh molar.
Now that we know the concentration
of hydronium ions in solution,
we can use our pH equation
to find the pH of water
at 50 degrees Celsius.
So we plug our concentration
of hydronium ions
into our equation,
and we take the negative log of that,
and we get that the pH is equal to 6.64.
Notice with two significant
figures for the concentration,
we get two decimal places for our answer.
If we had used Kw
is equal to 1.0 times
10 to the negative 14th,
we would've gotten a pH of 7.00,
but that's only true
at 25 degrees Celsius.
Since Kw is temperature dependent,
if the temperature is something other
than 25 degrees Celsius, the
pH of water will not be seven.
So in this case, we
calculated it to be 6.64.
The pH of pure water is
6.64 at 50 degrees Celsius.
However, water is still
a neutral substance.
The concentration of hydronium ions
is equal to the concentration
of hydroxide ions.